notre classe est parrainé par le
journaliste maurice gomis qui est en
résidence au nigeria il réalise des
reportages pour de grands médias
français et internationaux comme rfi
france 4 ou encore arte il nous
accompagne depuis le début de cette
aventure et de l'échangé avec nous
régulièrement partage son quotidien de
journalistes au nigeria quelles sont les
conditions d'exercice du métier de
journaliste dans les zones à risque nous
avons demandé à notre pas en nourrice
gomis de répondre à quelques questions
bonjour moïse pouvez vous nous dire
quels sont les risques du métier de
journaliste au nigeria bonjour de
manière générale journaliste quel que
soit l'endroit dans le monde aujourd'hui
c'est pas quelque chose des super simple
parce que on fait ce métier là et qu'on
essaie de décrire des réalités parfois
on va heurter des intérêts des intérêts
privés
on va déranger faire du journalisme et
quand comme le team dire y'a avec plein
plein de rennes très compliqué d'été est
obligé de le prendre des précautions
pour quoi qu'avez vous ressenti la
première fois que vous avez fait un
reportage dans une zone à risque
avez vous déjà eu peur pour vous bon
souviens très bien c'était en 2000 en
2015 dans le nord du nigeria
une ville qui s'appelle canaux il y
avait eu un attentat à la bombe dans la
grande mosquée et arrêté plusieurs
victimes tu te sens quand même une
montée d'adrénaline quand on part dans
une zone comme ça un peu à risque le
maître mot c'est la préparation au
prépare son voyage
on prépare ses déplacements au près par
ces rendez vous france 24 et rfi pour
lesquelles je travaille ne me laisse pas
partir s'il ne leur dit pas à l'avant ce
qui je vais voir où je vais comment j'y
vais et pourquoi j'y vais je dis tout un
travail à faire avec la rédaction
donc valide mon déplacement selon
reporters sans frontières il y a eu 50
journalisme hors de leur métier et 400
journalistes emprisonnés en 2020